[Applaus]
[Musik]
die türkei ein land mit mehr als 80
millionen einwohnern gilt traditionell
als eine der offensten und
fortschrittlichsten gesellschaft in der
islamischen welt lange zeit war sie der
einzige demokratischen staaten mit
muslimischer mehrheitsbevölkerung die
hinwendung zur freiheit moderne und
humanismus vector über viele jahrzehnte
auch große wirtschaftliche hoffnungen
das versprechen von wohlstand nach
westlichem vorbild galt für die türken
lange als durchaus real
[Musik]
zwischen 1999 und 2009 10 wuchs die
wirtschaft der türkei real um
durchschnittlich fast fünf prozent pro
jahr ein wachstum das die regierung mit
einem riesigen modernisierungsplan
unterstützte um straßen flughäfen häfen
und alle arten von infrastruktur zu
modernisieren und so wurde die türkei zu
einem magneten für investitionen und die
türken stiegen mit ihrem
einkommensniveau bis in den mittleren
bereich der globalen volkswirtschaften
auf die industrialisierung der
wirtschaft schon gewaltig voran das land
wurdest du eine mondäne touristen ziel
und es dann wohl zu einem wichtigen
finanzzentrum
das land am bosporus positionierte sich
als tor zur großregion als einer der
wichtigsten verbindungspunkt für den
zugang zu den märkten russlands des
nahen ostens und zentralasiens darüber
hinaus war das land ein angesehenes
mitglied der internationalen
gemeinschaft es war und ist irgendwie
noch immer mitglied der nato oder oecd
uns erst seit 1995 auch über ein
zollabkommen mit der europäischen union
das ihm bevorzugten zugang zum riesigen
gemeinsamen europäischen markt gewährt
vor diesem hintergrund kann es nicht
überraschen dass er im jahr 2018
nachrichten wie diese binden konnten
oktober 2008 sehen die türkei die große
erfolgsgeschichte der internationalen
wirtschaft ja das war 2018 seitdem haben
sich die dinge jedoch gewaltig verändert
der wirtschaftsboom der zwei jahrzehnte
lang millionen von menschen in die
mittelschicht befördert hatte ist
weitaus mehr als ins stocken geraten
die menschen und die türkische
wirtschaft stehen heute einer schweren
währungskrise gegenüber allein im jahr
2021 hat die türkische lira 50 prozent
ihres wertes gegenüber dem dollar
verloren die türken haben es mit nichts
geringerem als einem alptraum zu tun der
fast alle fortschritte um den wohlstand
der vergangenen jahrzehnte ausradiert
hat ein absturz der sogar in der
jetzigen krisenzeit seinesgleichen sucht
und das hat uns von visual politik
zusammen mit unseren freunden von value
school dazu gebracht uns eine frage zu
stellen was sind die wahren ursachen
dieses schrecklichen debatte denn wir
dürfen nicht auf den einfachen druck
schluss hereinfallen dies wäre ein
weiterer typischer fall in dem eine
regierung ihre zentralbank zwingt
unmengen geld zu drucken um ihre außer
kontrolle geratenen staatsausgaben zu
finanzieren ein unfall der eben
eingetreten wäre weil die regierung
keine andere wahl gehabt hätte nein im
fall der türkei haben werden in einer
kompletten konzertierten politischen und
wirtschaftlichen strategie zu tun ein
von anfang bis ende durchdacht
masterplan was genau passiert also mit
der türkischen wirtschaft nun lasst uns
eintauchen in die abgedrehte welt der
erdogan onyx und ich garantiere euch ihr
werdet aus dem staunen nicht mehr
herauskommen
das währungsdebatte
im jahr 2021 hat die türkische lehrer
massiv an wert verloren aber das war
nicht das erste mal und kam nicht vom
heiteren himmel bereits anfangen 2020
haben wir hier auf visual politik ein
video veröffentlicht indem wir genau
diesen absturz vorhergesagt haben da
geht es also bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren falls sie dieses video
gefällt und du in zukunft keines mehr
verpassen möchtest viele haben uns
damals belächelt oder sogar beschimpft
aber eines muss man sagen wenn man nur
einen funken klarem menschenverstand
besaß war die entwicklung der letzten
zwei jahre durchaus absehbar
sei recep tayyip erdogan im jahr 2004
präsident des landes geworden ist hat
die liga eine abwertung um fast 90
prozent litten
eine situation die natürlich
konsequenzen hat wir können dabei drei
haupt folgen identifizieren
die erste ist dass die inflation in die
höhe schoss offizielle zahlen deuten auf
eine inflationsrate von etwa 20
realistischere von der
regierungspropaganda unbeeinflusste
schätzungen deuten jedoch darauf hin
dass sie bereits 60 prozent
überschritten haben könnte zimmer
folgende grafik an
dieser dazu geführt dass viele familien
bei grundlegenden gütern wie fleisch
oder sogar brot schmerzhafte abstriche
machen mussten erst recht haben sie
probleme an importierte güter zu kommen
aber achtung das bedeutet nicht einfach
mal auf einen neuen fernseher zu
verzichten importiert werden nämlich zb
auch viele lebensnotwendige medikamente
eine derart massive abwertung gegenüber
den ausland also gravierende
gesundheitliche folgen für die
bevölkerung
[Musik]
zwei versuchen türkische sparer jene
lehrer die sich verdienen so schnell wie
möglich instabile auslandswährungen wie
us dollars aber auch gold oder crypto
währungen zu tauschen und das schadet
dem türkischen finanzsystem erheblich
denn zum einen beschleunigt dieser
prozess die abwertung der lira noch
weiter und zum anderen trägt er durch
bargeldabhebungen dazu bei die
devisenreserven des landes aufzubauen
und das kann dazu führen dass die
regierung strenge kapitalkontrollen
einführt
drittens hat der zusammenbruch der liga
zu einer enormen flucht von
ausländischem kapital geführt so dass zb
die bestände an anleihen und aktien
hätten ausländische investoren in den
letzten jahren um mehr als 70 prozent
gesunken sind auf dieser grafik kannst
du dir dieses trauerspiel ansehen
und das ist noch nicht alles um die
lehrer zu stützen hat die türkische
zentralbank mehrmals mit dem verkauf von
fremdwährungen in den markt eingegriffen
wodurch die netto fremdwährungsreserven
des landes aufgebraucht wurden mit
anderen worten die türkische wirtschaft
steht vor sehr sehr ernsten problemen
und nimm dich in acht denn es gibt nicht
wenige investoren analysten und ökonomen
erwarten dass dies erst der anfang ist
und es noch viel viel schlimmer kommen
dort aber was um alles in der welt
passiert dann mit der türkischen
wirtschaft aufgepasst
die glaubensfrage
um unsere antwort auf die frage näher zu
kommen was mit der türkischen wirtschaft
um alles in der welt los ist bitte ich
dich dir mal folgende grafik aufmerksam
anzusehen
gibt es darin etwas was deine
aufmerksamkeit erregt etwas das dir hier
überraschend seltsam vorkommt genau
obwohl die inflation in die höhe schießt
und sich die lehrer im sturzflug
befindet senkt die türkische zentralbank
die zinsen der plan scheint sogar zu
sein sie noch weiter in den keller zu
jagen und das ist eben genau das
gegenteil von dem was man normalerweise
in solchen situationen tut
[Musik]
das gegenteil von dem was in jedem
lehrbuch über volkswirtschaft und
geldpolitik steht denn um die inflation
einzudämmen kapitalflucht zu verhindern
und zu verhindern dass der dollar
stärker wird was zum beispiel die
rückzahlung von fremdwährungsdarlehen
die zentralbanken in der regel die
zinssätze und die türkei versucht eben
genau andersherum daher lautet die frage
warum zum teufel tun sie das
nun dass alles läuft auf eine art von
wirtschaftspolitik hinaus die bereits
als erdogan onyx in anspielung an
erdogan und economics also
wirtschaftswissenschaften bekannt ist
für uns ganz eigene privat vwl ist
nämlich der schlüsselfaktor durch
welchen sich die enorme krise der
türkischen lehrer erklären lässt der
allmächtige türkische präsident
behauptet nämlich davon überzeugt zu
sein dass eine senkung der zinssätze
durch die zentralbank zu einer
niedrigeren inflation führen wird aus
seiner sicht würde dieser prozess
folgendermaßen ablaufen niedrigere
zinssätze fördern investitionen
investitionen steigern die produktion
was wiederum produkte billiger macht die
exporte ankurbelt und das land reicher
macht kurz gesagt könnte man sagen dass
eine senkung der zinssätze erdogan
gleichbedeutend mit einer
subventionierung von investitionen ist
nach erdogans theorie spielt überhaupt
keine rolle was mit um import abhängigen
lieferketten rohstoffen ausländischen
investitionen oder der kaufkraft der
türkische sparer passiert
was der wechselkurse rennen steigt heute
und fällt morgen das was der inflation
nennen steigt heute und fällt morgen
produktion und beschäftigung sind
dauerhaft recep tayyip erdogan präsident
der türkei
zu erdogan befindet sich die türkische
wirtschaft in einer eigenen babbel und
irgendwie scheint an ihm vorbeigegangen
zu sein dass wir in einer hochgradig
vernetzten welt leben und die
wirtschaftlichen erfolge und
produktivitätssteigerungen der letzten
jahrzehnte vor allem auf dieser
verletzung internationaler
arbeitsteilung und spezialisierung
basieren naja warum sollte sich auch ein
mächtiger neo sultan mit solchen
nervigen details beschäftigen wenn es
doch ums große ganze geht und genau
deshalb habe er die türkische
zentralbank während seiner gesamten
amtszeit und insbesondere im jahr 2029
dazu gedrängt die zinssätze zu senken
das ultimative ziel des präsidenten ist
es die zinsen schließlich auf null zu
setzen und mit drängt meinen wir nicht
bloß wohlmeinende ratschläge erdogan hat
bereits fünf spitzenbeamte zentralbank
entlassen weil sie seinen plan nicht
zugestimmt haben
er versteht die wirtschaft nicht und die
leute um ihn herum verstehen die
wirtschaft nicht er ist auf einem
anderen planeten in einem anderen
universum ahmet davutoglu ehemaliger
ministerpräsident der türkei und
ehemaliger verbündeter von recep tayyip
erdogan
das alles ist umso verwunderlicher als
erdogan eigentlich am anfang seiner
nationalen karriere als großer kämpfer
gegen die inflation angetreten war und
diesen kurs lange zeit und mit großem
erfolg durchgehalten hat denn die türkei
litt bereits 1970 er jahren bis zum jahr
2000 unter e mails ohne inflationsraten
in vielen jahren durchbrachen diese
sogar die 100 prozent marke die preise
verdoppelten sich also damals von jahr
zu jahr aus diesem grund stehen die
türkei damals viele jahre lang zur
stagnation verurteilt bis zum jahr 2003
denn in diesem jahr kam erdogan an die
macht und er sollte zum großen
wirtschaftlichen erlöser des landes
werden ja das meine ich vollkommen ernst
0 ironie sein hauptziel war es die
inflation unter zehn prozent zu halten
er schuf eine neue währung die neue
türkische lira eine währung die viel
stabiler war als die vorherige und
nachdem er die inflation unter kontrolle
gebracht hatte erlebte die türkische
wirtschaft einen nie dagewesenen buch
auf einmal sogar in viele europäische
unternehmen in der türkei zu investieren
in den 2000er jahren war die türkei
total hipp
[Musik]
[Applaus]
damals wollte sie europäisch sein sie
schickte sich an ein mitglied der
europäischen union zu werden
rechtsstaatlichkeit und
währungsstabilität ermöglicht es
unternehmen ihr kapital im land zu
reinvestieren in weniger als zehn jahren
erhöhte sich das durchschnittsgehalt
eines türkischen arbeiters von 800 us
dollar auf mehr als 1.200 us dollar im
monat aber das war nicht alles in diesen
ersten regierungsjahren erdogans wuchsen
neue industrien heran türkische
unternehmen wurden zu global playern in
den 90er jahren war zum beispiel turkish
airlines eine von vielen kleinen
fluggesellschaften aber da sie nun dank
der stabilen landeswährung ihre gewinne
wieder reinvestieren konnte wurde sie zu
einem luftbad gegangen
das gleiche galt für viele andere
türkische konzerne wie zb die yildiz
holdings die viele europäische marken
eco de france und united biscuits
aufkaufte und zum drittgrößten
lebensmittelunternehmen der welt
heranwuchs und ja dieses
wirtschaftswunder fußte auf der
währungspolitik an der stabilen die ihre
eines bestimmten mannes recep tayyip
erdogan doch dann vollzog diese eine
wende um 180 grad was also ist mit
erdogan passiert wie kann er plötzlich
auf diese verrückte idee dass man
inflation mit niedrigen zinsen bekämpft
warum glaubt er dass der beste weg mit
einem inflationsszenario und dem
zusammenbruch der ihrer umzugehen darin
besteht die zinssätze noch weiter zu
senken nun ja das problem ist dass er
keinen dieser fatalen idee schon immer
im kopf des recep tayyip erdogan
vorhanden war diese seite wartete die
ganze zeit nur auf den richtigen moment
ist die hervor schießt und alle anderen
prämissen seines handelns zu überwuchern
alle früchte seiner vorherigen
bemühungen und handlungen sollten sich
als bloßes futter für diese saat
herausstellen 1998 hatte erdogan gesagt
die demokratie ist nur der zug auf den
wir aufsteigen bis wir am ziel sind und
ebenso wie die demokratie benutzte er
die stabile währungs und
wirtschaftspolitik die ganze zeit nur
als ein mittel um einen anderen
übergeordneten zweck zu erreichen
denn alles was erdogan tut und das
türkische volk tun lässt ist letztlich
auf ein bestimmtes ziel ausgerichtet der
total islamisierung heute der türkei
aber morgen schon der ganzen welt
natürlich mit erdogan als unumstrittene
anführer und seine aktuelle
wirtschaftspolitik basiert auf nichts
anderem als auf einer ideologischen
linie wirtschaftlichen handelns die ende
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts aufkam und
als islamische ökonomie bekannt ist eine
theorie die den zins als den mutter
allen übels betrachtet passt nun gut
auch wenn wir nähern uns dem auge dieses
ganzen sturms und darin wird deutlich
spannend denn angesichts von zwei
milliarden muslimen die heute auf diesem
planeten leben haben der es nichts
geringerem als dem versuch der
errichtung einer neuen ideologisch
geprägten geo ökonomischen und
geopolitischen weltordnung zu tun welche
viele gar nicht auf ihrem radar haben
islamische wirtschaft
die erste tat sache die wir uns da
gegenwärtigen müssen ist dass der koran
den sogenannten riba das verleihen von
geld zugewinn zwecken scharf verurteilt
der reva acs dabei sogar namentlich mit
zudem sechs haupt sünden des koran die
da wären nord glaube an andere götter
außer allah ungesetzliche aneignung des
vermögens von waisenkindern feigheit vor
dem feind anklage von kosten formen
frauen und eben der riba deshalb ist die
scharia das islamische recht der meinung
dass geld ein einfaches tauschmittel sei
und als solches nicht zur
gewinnerzielung verwendet werden darf
die festsetzung eines im voraus
festgelegt nun festen zins dass es
könnte also gegen das islamische recht
verstoßen wie so vieles im koran ist
aber auch der riba nicht ganz klar darin
definiert sind damit auch zinsen als
aufwandsentschädigung gemeint oder nur
bucher oder auch irgendwas dazwischen
historisch gesehen haben viele
islamische rechtsgelehrte daher zwischen
übermäßig ausbeuterischen geldverleihern
und solchen mit vernünftigen zinssätzen
unterschieden dies ermöglichte zum
beispiel den betrieb von geld stiftungen
im osmanischen reich selbst welche
kredite gegen zinsen anboten später kam
es auch zur gründung echter banken in
der ganzen islamischen welt in der
zweiten hälfte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts wurde es jedoch kompliziert
damals kam die theorie der islamischen
ökonomie auf die nicht nur von
marxistischen ideen beeinflusst war
sondern auch zu einer extremen auslegung
des riga zurückkehrte
mit anderen worten die islamischen
ökonomie verurteilt zinsen wieder aufs
schärfste und nein für diese
wirtschaftstheorie handelt es sich nicht
nur um eine frage der moral sie besagt
nämlich dass zinsen am ende zu mehr
inflation mehr armut und weniger
wirtschaftswachstum führen
und wisst ihr was erdogan ist ein
bekennender anhänger der islamischen
wirtschaftslehre in der tat hat er
seinen krieg gegen die zinsen öffentlich
mit aussagen wie dieser verteidigt
es gibt einen ast ein göttliches dekret
im koran zu diesem thema liegt es also
an der oder am meer recep tayyip erdogan
präsident der türkei
mit anderen worten er hat sein
politisches programm als religiöse
verpflichtung verteidigt die
ausdrücklich kein guter muslim in frage
stellen sollte und achtung zu erdogan
ist die welt absolut in schwarz und weiß
aufgeteilt einen ausdruck wie gemäßigter
islam endet er als hässlich respektlos
und als eine beleidigung seiner religion
für ihn gibt es keinen gemäßigten oder
um gemäßigten islam sondern nur einen
islam seine herrschaft seit absolut und
da er sich selbst als bester und
oberster verfechter dieses einen
absoluten islam sieht müsse auch seine
macht absolut seiner das ist die große
herausforderung vor der die türkei heute
steht und die so viele probleme
verursacht
[Musik]
ein präsident der die kontrolle über
alle wichtigen institutionen des landes
übernommen hat darunter die zentralbank
die universitäten und den großteil der
medien ein präsident der sich eine art
von wirtschaftspolitik verschrieben hat
deren fatale ergebnisse immer deutlicher
werden und ein präsident der nicht
bereit zu sein scheint seinen eigenen
fehler einzusehen und seine strategie zu
ändern und so wurden wir auch kürzlich
anfang dezember 2021 zeugen folgender
nachricht
der türkische finanzminister tritt
inmitten des dia sturzes zurück lud wl
warnte zurück und wird durch nureddin
debatte einem erdogan loyalisten ersetzt
wie elf andere als letzte stimme der
wirtschaftlichen orthodoxie im kabinett
des türkischen staates galt hat darum
gebeten von seinen aufgaben entbunden zu
werden
ganz genau schuld an den verlorenen
schlachten haben immer die generäle sie
haben einfach nicht stark genug an die
sache glaubt der endsieg könnte dabei in
greifbarer nähe sein wenn sie nicht
dauernd ihren führer verraten würden
alle müssten nur noch ein bisschen
länger durchhalten und noch fester an
ihn glauben schließlich lässt er doch
eine wunderwaffe nach der anderen
entwickeln welche die langersehnte wende
bringen werden
erdogan kündigt die ausarbeitung einer
neuen verfassung der türkei für 2022 an
ja wäre nicht der erste der kein problem
damit hat sein volk in den untergang zu
führen nur um stur an einer bestimmten
ideologie festhalten zu können
angesichts dessen was wir gesehen haben
sie die zukunft der türkei alles andere
als hoffnungsvoll aus
[Musik]
aber natürlich sind nicht alle so
pessimistisch und es gibt einige
analysten die darauf hinweisen dass sich
die lage sehr schnell verbessern könnte
falls es durch ein rasches umdenken zu
einer stabilisierung kommt entweder
durch einen zumindest zeitweisen 180
grad schwenk erdogan es wäre ich der
erste oder dass es bei den nächsten
wahlen zu einem regierungswechsel käme
es gibt sogar investoren die glauben
gerade jetzt sei die zeit zu der man
sich die wirtschaft der türkei zum
schnäppchenpreis einverleiben können und
bei einer anschließenden erholung den
großen reibach einzufahren so dass zb
die spanischen großbank bbva
fünfzehnter november 2021 bbva
unterbreitet ein übernahmeangebot für
die türkischen bank garanti sie bietet
für jede hälfte die sie noch nicht
kontrolliert
2,249 milliarden euro
und was weißt du wird ist der türkei
gelingen sich aus dieser schwierigen
situation zu befreien ist es ein guter
zeitpunkt um in der türkei zu
investieren oder ist das länderrisiko zu
groß wird die türkei ein noch größeres
risiko für investitionen wäre es
vielleicht besser abzuwarten bis es so
richtig kracht und was hältst du von der
islamischen wirtschaftstheorie stellt
sie eine echte konkurrenz für die beiden
anderen wirtschaftsmodelle da die um die
weltherrschaft ringen den westlichen
markt kapitalismus und den chinesischen
stars kapitalismus wie immer sind wir
auf deine meinung zu diesem thema schon
sehr gespannt ich hoffe also dass ihr
dieses video gefallen hat falls ja gib
uns bitte einen leid empfehle es deinen
freunden vergiss nicht dass aber mit
glück noch keines unserer videos messer
verpassen und unterstütze bitte unsere
arbeit auch mit einer kleinen spende
über den link in der beschreibung unter
diesem video machs gut und bis bald
[Musik]